adorable insertion burn was scheduled to
take place 31 minutes after launch uh
but uh didn't happen on schedule
boeing's starliner spaceship was sent
back to the factory in august
nasa had planned to launch the starliner
for a crewless test flight to the iss or
international space station this past
summer but the space agency and boeing
postponed the mission after a valve
issue was discovered on the vehicle
before launch
boeing executives had talked about this
flight as one of great importance for
the company and staff had spent months
working through every issue from the
first flight challenges with space
technology or vehicles aren't uncommon
both boeing's starliner project and its
competitor spacex's dragon crew capsule
have been delayed multiple times but how
did boeing accompany with such a long
history that the cutting edge of the
space industry suffers so many setbacks
five four three
two since the height of the cold war
boeing's name has been synonymous with
ambitious american space endeavors some
of its biggest accomplishments include
vehicles for the apollo program which
sent humans to the moon in 2014 nasa
contracted two companies spacex and
boeing to create two different space
vehicles that would serve as the next
generation of spaceships to transport
crew to the iss spacex had been around
for a little more than a decade it was
still a relatively young company
still building out its operations and
technology whereas boeing
had you know been working with nasa for
for decades since the space shuttle's
retirement in 2011 and until 2020 the us
did not have the capability to transport
crude to orbit
and liftoff for about a decade nasa
relied on russia's so used rocket to get
american crews to the iss boeing's
starliner was designed to
take astronauts to the international
space station and get them home boeing's
is attached on top of a rocket which
separates after that initial launch it's
meant to travel and dock with the space
station and lift off the rise of
starliner and a new era in human space
flight in 2019 boeing and nasa attempted
to send an uncrewed starliner to the iss
with much fanfare now passing one minute
into flight but that test flight failed
due to two programming errors the
spacecraft's internal timer was off by
11 hours stranding it in the wrong orbit
and preventing it from reaching the
international space station
boeing's cst-100 starliner capsule did
however return to earth safely so we did
have obviously some challenges today
when the when the spacecraft separated
from the launch vehicle
we did not get the orbital insertion
burn that we were hoping for
another potentially catastrophic error
was fixed during the mission one error
sent the starliner to the wrong orbit
and then the second involved software
that controls thrusters that help angle
the craft to avoid damaging a heat
shield which protects the vehicle during
re-entry software emerged after the
flight failed as a sort of a major issue
that boeing needed to address for a
future attempt after the flight nasa's
leadership was concerned that boeing had
a broader cultural problem in light of
the 737 max crisis which involved two
fatal crashes in indonesia and ethiopia
the agency ordered a sweeping outside
review resulting in dozens of
recommendations
the failure of the 2019 starliner test
mission was a big deal for boeing
boeing was still grappling with the
fallout from the 737 max crisis a
successful starliner mission was seen as
a way to help restore its reputation for
reliability and engineering prowess
in december 2019 boeing's board already
frustrated by the max crisis ousted
boeing ceo dennis muellenberg then in
august boeing and the space agency said
they would again postpone the redo of
the test mission because some valves on
the starliner's propulsion system became
stuck before launch
nasa declined to comment last week the
agency said earlier in october that it
and boeing were making progress
investigating the starliner's valves in
a statement boeing said it is focused on
supporting our nasa customer and the
path forward will be driven by safety
and thorough testing we have full
confidence in our ability to deliver
starliner for its ultimate mission
nasa said the vehicle won't launch again
this year the space agency also shifted
two astronauts who had been assigned to
fly on starliner missions to a future
spacex flight nasa said it was shifting
these astronauts because it needed to
ensure that those astronauts were
getting space experience and it wanted
to give boeing time to develop the
starliner these most recent starliner
setbacks come at a challenging time for
boeing's business
after making record revenue in 2018
boeing has lost nearly half that amount
largely due to a sharp drop in
commercial aircraft deliveries and max
related charges
today the company is more reliant on its
space business than it was in the past
boeing space program is a key part of
its defense space and security unit
boeing generated more than six billion
in revenue from space related work last
year and that accounted for a little
more than 10 percent of you know all of
the company's revenue for that year to
date boeing's starliner development has
cost 3.2 billion dollars while spacex's
dragon has cost far less at 2.6 billion
what's more unlike boeing spacex has
managed to get crude missions into space
there's the crew on the right hand side
of your screen i think i see some more
thumbs up there
[Music]